hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Section seven of being and time
Martin Heidegger is introducing us to
the very notion of phenomenology and he
discusses the notion or the concept of
phenomenon the what we call phenomenon
in English on one side and then he talks
about the ology but he focuses on the
logos that that comes from we when we
say ology we're talking about some sort
of discipline but that's coming from a
logos you know which is typically as he
points out translated as a speech or
reason he also focuses in judgment some
sort of discourse very often and we want
to clarify the the meaning of logos so
he tells us at the beginning of this
this section that this concept of logos
has many meanings in two great thinkers
Plato and Aristotle indeed in such a way
these meanings diverged without a basic
meaning positively taking the lead he
wants to get at what that basic meaning
would be so he thinks that we have to go
you might say to some degree behind
Plato and Aristotle in terms of time and
culture but we also do need to draw a
leading clue from Aristotle's own
treatment of the matter without thereby
remaining committed to Aristotle's
account of it so he says that we have to
adequately grasp the basic meaning in
its primary content this is what
Heidegger and other places calls a
primordial conception so he says if we
say the basic meaning of logos is
something like speech talking right or a
discourse then the literal translation
becomes valid only when we do something
else what is that define what speech
means or language or discourse that's
not quite so easy
to do he says the latter history of the
word logos conceal constantly the real
meaning of speech which is manifest it's
enough logos becomes translated and that
always means interpreted as reasoned
judgment concept definition ground
relation and and we could actually go on
it has further meanings in in ancient
Greek sometimes it can even come to mean
something like lie or just story that
you're telling all right so Heidegger
says that's not very helpful we need to
back up a bit we need to try to recover
what the primordial original Greek
meaning of logos is and we really need
to get away from thinking that logo
somehow signifies judgment or set of
judgments so he says rather logos as
speech we're looking at this sort of
beginning meaning of it logos as speech
really means and uses a Greek word de
Lune meaning to manifest to show forth
to display to another to make clear is
another translation of that
so speaking shows us things it doesn't
just operate a code it's not simply
playing a language game it's connected
with the world that we live in maybe not
in a simple way where each word means
one thing but language allows us to show
things to each other and to ourselves he
goes on and he says and introduces
another Greek term here for us right he
says de Lune means making manifest what
is talked about in speech Aristotle here
he's going to follow Aristotle to a
certain degree explains this more
precisely with another Greek term Apple
finest thigh so Apple is in this case
translated as from itself right and the
finest I is to display to to allow
something to be seen to show or as we're
going to see a little bit later on to
reveal in the sense of unconcealed so
Apple fantasize the verb and we're going
to get Apple fonts this as another Greek
term that Heidegger is going to use here
as the sort of noun conforming to that
verb the activity of apple fauna sigh
the activity of displaying through
language is Apple Fonz's so here are
Heidegger says something quite important
that I think I've got it laid out
slightly here on the board but we're
going to have to talk our way through
this he says speech lets us see from
itself what is being talked about right
Apple fauna say is something being seen
namely whatever is being revealed for
the speaker when we talk we're not just
revealing something to the others we're
also in a certain sense revealing
something for ourselves that that may be
something well worth dwelling upon so
there's also this element of speaking to
other people right something is being
revealed for the speaker who serves as
Heidegger says as the medium or for
those who speak with each other there's
a difference between merely speaking to
another and speaking with another
sometimes we actually do both in the
same conversation or a discourse but
this is something again worth worth
thinking about how does speech reveal
things to us how does it make things
able to be seen able to be perceived
able to be understood
so he goes and he says in speech insofar
as it's genuine what is said should be
derived from what is being talked about
so in this way says spoken communication
makes manifest what it's talking about
and thus makes accessible to another and
he says this is the structure of logic
as both fonts Asst again we see the the
Greek term being used there and he tells
us not all talking actually manages to
bring this off all right he says not
every speech in quotes suits this mode
of making manifest requesting make
something manifest but in a different
way a UK could also mean praying too so
he goes on and he says that when fully
concrete speech has the character of
speaking or vocalization in words logos
is phone a phone a is an intelligible
sound so what we get phonetics from
right indeed and he uses another Greek
locution here phone a meta font osseous
which he translated vocalization in
which something always is cited but
that's actually an interesting term
because we could also say a speech or
sound an intelligible vocalization
beyond the imagination or the appearance
right at the fantasy s now he goes on
and he says because of this this this
function of logos as apophysis let's
something to be seen this is the reason
why logos can have the structure of what
we call synthesis and this is another
greek term sin means to gather basis is
a kind of setting or placing and
normally when we talk about synthesis we
talk about having you know things and
bringing them together into some sort of
new combination or hole so we might talk
about a dish as a wonderful synthesis of
you know
this kind of flavor profile in this kind
of flavor profile using this kind of
vegetables right and we said well we're
we're fusing them together and we might
think about speech is doing something
like that with the words and the things
and ourselves Heidegger says no let's
really putting the cart before the horse
synthesis occurs later on the width is
actually a more primordial one a more
originally one he says the sin of
synthesis here has a purely Apple Fanta
chol meaning that it means it's it's
revealing something to us to let
something be seen in what in its
togetherness with something to be let
something be seen as something we often
think about the world as a bunch of
isolated objects that we can break down
further and to other isolated objects
that are associated into systems that is
not our actual experience of the world
or of ourselves or of what it is to
speak with another person we grasp
things already in the mist of other
things with them connected with them
separable from them distinguishable from
them but they're with them it's not as
if we first have the things and then
only afterwards does togetherness occur
now he goes on here and he brings in
another idea that's going to be very
important throughout Heidegger's work
and it plays a very key role here in the
notion of what's going on in logos truth
for Heidegger is fundamentally or
primarily Alafaya
that's the the Greek word for truth
which means there's a privat of a you
know out of against not Laith a which
means concealment forgetfulness
so a lethea means bringing things or
things coming out of their concealment
we often translate this as on
concealment here he also talks in terms
of discovery uncovering something when
we discover something we don't make
something up that's completely new right
we come across it and we didn't realize
that it was already there so he says
because logos let something be seen it
can therefore be true or false what is
it the truth or falsity he says we have
to avoid any sort of correspondence
theory of truth you know the notion of
truth is being as he says correspondence
or accordance you been skimming this
whole notion of like an equation is
another way of talking about it you know
adequacy or a at the intellect 'm
intellectus the the ad equation or
equality even between mind and things
right or language and things Heidegger
says that that's a derivative conception
of truth
likewise he's going to insist here that
truth is also not to be understood
primarily in terms of judgement
judgement rutile comes later in the
actual story but we will often get mixed
up about this in part because truth is
Correspondence is a very seductive
notion that that that would somehow
encapsulate when all truth is really
about so he goes down and he says being
true of logos as a leaf a lane of
literally making true or unrevealing or
revealing or unconcealed means to take
beings that are being talked about in
legging and in speech as apple finest
thigh out of their concealment so what
are we what are we talking about there
he's mixed in some Greek terms speech as
Alethea means to talk in such a way
that we show forth we display to each
other or to ourselves what it is that
those beings are perhaps even what it is
that those beings are in themselves or
in light of other beings Zoe says this
is to discover them similarly being
false Sudha stai in in Greek in some
respect literally being lied about right
is tantamount he says to deceiving in
the sense of covering up there's a
couple different modalities of falseness
that he talks about and they all come
back to the same idea
covering up right concealing placing one
thing in the place of another putting he
says putting something in front of
something else that is letting the the
one thing be seen so that the other
thing won't be seen and thereby passing
it off as something that it is not let's
dwell on that for a moment with some
examples he doesn't provide some here
but I think this may be helpful when we
engage in euphemism we are in a certain
way lying and gating engaging in su
Desai and Greek about what the thing is
to somebody else or perhaps to ourselves
so calling the harpy's you know the
peaceful or you know blessed ones or
anything along those lines
the Furies rather is is concealing that
the reality of that when I tell myself
it doesn't really matter whether I
exercise or not so long as I have the
right you know idea about my body type
I'll lose weight no matter what I'm
lying to myself right if I tell myself
something about this chalkboard call it
something that it isn't I'm concealing
something and I concealed by placing one
thing in place of another
lying or falsehood is always going to be
you could say parasitical upon truth in
this primordial sense so he goes on
Annie says because truth has this
meaning because logos is a mode of
letting something be seen logos simply
may not be acclaimed as the primary
place of truth logos is not the only
place where truth is happening so he
says if one defines truth is what
genuinely pertains to judgment which is
very customary today or we might also
talk especially in terms of the
correspondence theory things are true
when there are there objectively the way
things really are
that's a correspondence theory of truth
that's derivative that's less primordial
for Heidegger than this this more
originally conception of truth is a
lethea so he says if we define this this
procedures without justification and the
Greek concept of truth is thoroughly
misunderstood so he says in the Greek
sense of what is true and here he brings
up two other terms and the rest of this
paragraph I thesis which we usually
translate as perception oftentimes sense
perception seeing things hearing things
smelling things all of that he says we
we actually grasp the beings as they
reveal themselves to us or we describe
them and thereby reveal themselves to to
us as well right
to the extent a nice thesis aims at its
idea what is its own the beings
genuinely accessible to it so looking at
at colors he says perception is always
true what is the in the purest and most
original sense true is pure he says
knowing and this is another greek term
we often translate this as intellection
right the operation of what goes beyond
the senses that and we often associate
this with what makes us part
a human as opposed to the other animals
here Heidegger's is calling that
straightforwardly observe observant
apprehension of the simplest
determinations of the being of beings as
such he says knowing cannot be false
either at worst it can be sort of not
working an on apprehending not suffice
in for appropriate access so how do
thinks that we actually do have this
sort of basic you might call it
interconnection with the world with
ourselves with others through these
things it can be mediated through
language in fact it often does have to
be mediated through language this is
what the logos at its core is
fundamentally about that doesn't mean
that we have some sort of naive realism
whereas everything is always exactly as
we think it is or as we say it is that's
not at all what he's talking about here
as a matter of fact that would be
predicated on something more like a
truth is correspondence theory now he
goes on and he says truth of judgment is
actually only the opposite of covering
up it's actually what he calls a
multiplied founded phenomenon of truth
so that realism and idealism both missed
the meaning of the Greek concept of
truth and he says because the function
of logos lies and letting something be
seen straightforwardly letting beings be
apprehended logos can therefore the last
thing is going to say logos can also
mean reason this capacity that we have
for grasping how things are and that
means in part their relationships with
other things so he's going to go on and
bring up a few more terms he says logos
can be understood both as leg gain that
is the speaking and as legoman tone that
which is spoken about all right he says
it's used in both of these senses so he
says what always already lies present at
the basis of all relevant speech and
discussion
because of this logos as let go Menon
means it's ground or rat CEO rat see
also means reason he says because it can
also mean what is addressed as something
that has become visible in its relation
to something else in its relatedness
logos also acquires the meaning of
relation and relationship so logos
encompasses a lot all of this is said
remember to not just to explicate what
logos as a term means or even just to
talk about the primordial conception of
truth but as part of a larger
conversation in this section about what
phenomenology the logos of fine omen a
finite phenomenon right would happen to
be so Heidegger is telling you all of
this in order to help clarify his
conception of phenomenology as a
discipline
you